I was probably one of the sickest that
they've had coming through the hospital.
In 2017, I got to represent my country
in both wheelchair rugby league
and in wheelchair tennis.
I still pinchmyself at the opportunity every day.
I m Stephan, I m 26 years old and
I was born with spina bifida.
Doctors said basically I wouldn t have anychance of living past 24 hours because I
was just too sick. When I was born, I hadthe head size of Jimmy Neutron basically.
Your body I think naturally will drain out brainfluid from your head and throughout your body. And
so unfortunately, that's what my body can'tdo and so that s why I've got the machine,
the shunt, put into my head.
It canhave a lot of impacts. For me personally,
I can feel my body right on through to my anklesand unfortunately, I can't feel my feet.
I'm a part time walker, if you want to
call it that. I can walk short distances.
In high school I didn t feelcomfortable very much in my own skin.
It was all about trying to fit in to the bestof my ability and I really thought to myself,
you know, I'm really different. Like my upper body is growing
the way that it should but unfortunately, mylegs are still looking like cricket stumps.
Growing up as a kid, I was always kicking aroundwith the footy and everything like that. I'm
a huge West Tigers fan.
You know as I got olderand understood the severity of my disability,
I knew that dream was starting to really
get further and further away from me.
So that's why at the age of 12
I decided to pick up wheel-chair
tennis to at least give me some sort
of hope of becoming an athlete.
I was asked quite a few insensitive questions
in high school and every single time that I'd
be associated with getting a girlfriend
or anything like that my peers around me
would always say you know, are they also in awheelchair, are they disabled as well? and so
that's where I kind of really thought to
myself, no, people with a disability can
be in mainstream relationships as well. I
really took offence to it at the time.
I guess the negative thoughts at that time
really took over me and really swamped me and
the conversations I was having with myself
was, you know, "mate you're a piece of shit".
I was stuck in that cycle for I'd say a good three
years. The turning point definitely for me was
having a conversation with my tennis coach.
Wetalked about what's going on, how I viewed myself,
my value to myself, how I thought
my value was to people around me.
My tennis coach had exposed me to a
simple exercise really which is two
things that you're grateful for and one thing
that you found challenging throughout your day.
That for me, was the real kicker.
It's definitelyhelped my mental state in terms of understanding
myself better and understanding my limitations
as an individual, both physically and mentally,
and what I can look to aspire to be like.
Wheelchair rugby league, it was just a thing
that just came about for me in 2013 and I
was always looking for the opportunity.
It's a
bit like OzTag but in a wheelchair but it still
doesn't obviously stop you from smashing into
someone and having them fall to the ground.
It's a sport that is inclusive. So you
don't actually need to have a disability
to actually play the sport, which is the
best thing.
Wheelchair rugby league has
especially made me feel like I belong,
because I guess it's the closest thing
with our able-bodied counterparts that we can
actually be a part of so I'm always being included
in NRL things and I'm able to be surrounded by
all the people that I idolised growing up.
In 2017, I got to represent my country
in both wheelchair rugby league and in
wheelchair tennis. And I couldn t have been
any prouder for that year to have occurred.
I've also kickstarted up a modelling career. I
really wanted to start that primarily because of
how I viewed myself growing up as an individual
and I really wanted to recreate the narrative
of how the industry really sees models where
they have to be six foot tall and tall,
skinny and all these sorts of things that a
lot of people can't aspire to be like.
And so
that's where I really want to be able to start
those conversations of having disabled models be
more featured in mainstream advertisements.
I was very single for a long time to the point
where I was making dinner for two and eating
both.
Brooke is amazing. How she has picked up
the perspective of me living with a disability and
how she's able to aid me and still be able to
give me the sense of independence that I still
crave as an individual living with a disability
is something that, you know, I love to have. And
she complements me again so well apart
from the fact you go for Cronulla babe.
We always tend to have the one or two people
that kinda look at us where it's like, you know,
is that who he's dating? And I always have
sort of grin on my face thinking, yeah,
that's who I'm dating. That's not my carer.
That's my girlfriend.
I love you, babe.
I definitely feel like there
is a silence and how we
how we disrupt that is by speaking about it
more, whether that be through dinner talks or
you know whether or not we see someone on the
street and just having a general conversation
about that.
I feel that if we have more
normality around conversations of disability
in open spaces especially, I think that's when
we can really start to change the narrative of
mental health and disabled people
going hand-in-hand with each other.